اللواء عريقات كيف تقرا ما تقول اسرائيل
بانها انجازات تحققها لا سما في خانيونس
يعني الانجازات من وجهه نظرهم هي الجرائم
التي
ترتكبها حرب الاباده الجماعيه التطهير
العرقي سياسه الارض المحروقه تدمير
المباني يعني حتى
الان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يقم الا بالقتل
لم يقاتل حقيقه الذي يقاتل هو المقاوم
الذي يشتبك مع الجيش الاسرائيلي يعني انا
بتقديري 111 يوم يتحدثون عن حجم الاهداف
التي تم قصفها وهي طبعا استهدفت المدنيين
اي نتحدث عن اكثر من 26000 شهيد ما يقارب
63000 جريح تدمير بنيه تحتيه تدمير جامعات
تدمير مدارس اي تجريب شوارع الاليات التي
تستخدم هي التي حقيقه تعمل على الارض وليس
الجنود الاسرائيليين في مواجهه المقاتلين
فلذلك نحن نتحدث عن جرائم عن سقوط اخلاقي
للجيش الاسرائيلي عن حجم كبير من الدماء
والدموع الفلسطينيين عن قتل الحياه عن
محاوله تهجير الفلسطينيين الضغط عليهم
سواء كان من الشمال الى الجنوب نلاحظ ايضا
ان ال التقاسم او التناوب ما بين سلاح
الجو وسلاح المدفعيه البريه والبحريه على
مدار الساعه هو الذي يقوم بالعمل في
الميدان والعالم اعتقد انه يشاهد الان
بالصوت وبالصوره يعني لا يوجد لا يوجد
انجازات بمعنى الانجازات الحقيقيه للجيش
الاسرائيلي الا هذه المجازر اما الاهداف
التي انطلق من اجلها الجيش الاسرائيلي وهي
القضاء على المقاومه الفلسطينيه وتحرير
الاسرى بالقوه العسكريه لم يحدث طيب بدليل
ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي التي تقاتل وهي
التي تشتبك معهم في كل مكان وصلوا اليه
مما يقول ايضا جيش الاحتلال اللواء عريقات
مما يصفها بانجازات يقول بانه دمر وحيد
اعداد كبيره من الانفاق التي تستخدمها
كتائب القسام والفصائل الفلسطينيه الاخرى
ما قولك
بهذا يعني اولا الانفاق موجوده وليست يعني
مجهوله يعني الانفاق ما زال ما زال قسم
كبير منها يستخدم المقاتلين الفلسطينيين
لم يصلوا الى كل الاهداف بدليل انهم
يتحدثون عن عن صعوبه وعن عقد في وجه الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الوصول اليها ولكن هذه
الانفاق التي تم اكتشافها هذه لم لن تفيد
الجيش الاسرائيلي سو انه سيفجر ولن تضر
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لانها استخدمتها
واستنفذت يعني استخدمتها في المراحل
الاولى في التصدي للعدو الاسرائيلي وال
والحمايه من الطيران يعني كانت بمثابه
ملاجئ محصنه للمقاومين ولاسلفي ظل ضربات
الطيران والا ل قضوا عليهم كلهم هذا من
جانب من جانب اخر هذه الانفاق الان يعني
ماز ما زالت تعرق الجيش الاسرائيلي وتبطئ
من عمليات تقدمه لانه حينما يتقدم على
الارض هو يشعر بان كل متر يتقدم اليه هي
عباره عن نفق فلذلك هذا السلاح
الاستراتيجي الذي استنفذ من قبل المقاومين
التي تم كشفه الان لا لزوم له لانه هناك
التحام هناك التحام بين الجي الجيش
الاسرائيلي وبين المقاومين على الارض اما
التي ما زالت موجوده بقبضه المقاومين
اعتقد انها ما زالت فاعله
وتستخدم كسلاح استراتيجي مقابل الطيران
مقابل المدفعيه مقابل الدبابات مقابل
الجرافات فبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن سلاح ما
زال موجودا وفاعلا ولكن اسرائيل تريد ان
تعزي النفس وانا اعتقد انه يعني خير من
يتحدث عن هذه الهزيمه للجيش الاسرائيلي
الصحف الاسرائيليه التي تتحدث وتقول
بعناوينها ان الجيش يبحث عن عن اهداف يعني
غير مرئيه بالنسبه له والمقاومه تقضم
ذيوله يعني بمعنى او
اقتل